so who's my guest this week it is the
democratic senator foreign affairs
expert and former vice presidential
candidate tim kaine i'm sending a clear
message to the world america is back
america is back but as we've seen with
the conflict in ukraine diplomacy is far
more complicated than sound bites
president biden's performance regarding
russia and ukraine hasn't been graded
yet but for all the re-engagement there
have been missteps too
when that judgment is made my guest will
play a part
sitting on the senate committee on
foreign relations he's a washington pro
who's been within spitting distance of
the vice presidency twice now he's
focused on as he puts it protecting the
constitution from the enemies of
democracy foreign and domestic
and after suffering from long covid
ensuring those still affected by the
pandemic are not
forgotten with russia accused of war
crimes in ukraine how does he think
america and the world should deal with
vladimir putin
and on a more personal note how do you
get over nearly being vice president of
america
twice when john kerry became secretary
of state he had a knock at the door that
morning and it's john mccain he said i
got to tell you you and i are the only
people in the senate who have gone
through what you've just gone through
we're the only two now that have been on
a national ticket and lost and i'll tell
you i've got the solution for you and i
said i'm all ears he said just go right
back to work i said you found me here
first thing the first day we're open you
found me here didn't you there's been
multiple reports of war crimes now
including the raping of ukrainian women
russian authorities have denied all
if the evidence is there do you think
we'll ever see putin in the hague on
charges when you target civilians that's
a war crime and i believe he needs to
get the the slogan milosevic treatment
and the u.s needs to press for that
thank you so much for joining me very
good to have your company today
i wanted to start talking about how some
have described it
as confusing foreign policy under
president biden in one sense we get told
at the beginning of his administration
america's back and we see
quite quickly
in terms of diplomacy a first major
overseas act was to withdraw from
afghanistan and now we see engagement
with ukraine how would you define how it
is at the moment
um i think the um the the real key to
the biden administration america's back
is america's back to link arms with
allies that's the hallmark of this
administration that is the dramatic
departure
from the trump administration president
trump was a unilateral guy he didn't
like
alliances he didn't like treaties he
didn't like multi-party trade deals it
was all one-on-one
and that left many of america's
traditional allies wondering you know is
this just president trump or is the
united states even the citizenry uh kind
of retreating from linking arms with
allies well president biden with long
track record of chairing the foreign
relations committee in the senate his
work as vice president with leaders
around the world is back in a big way
whether it's getting back in the paris
climate accord restarting negotiations
with iran to see whether we can work in
a multi-nation deal to stop a nuclear
program there but most recently the work
in ukraine to assemble
nato and non-native donations in a very
very strong alliance to put multiple
pressure points on russia because of
their illegal invasion of ukraine i see
this as an administration that's really
committed to america's role in the world
but particularly in linking arms with
with allies and growing that number of
allies i suppose it's just i'm very
minded one of my guests the women's
minister of afghanistan yes and she's
now living out of a suitcase as a
refugee in london
thinking if america's back how am i in
this situation and she described the
most terrible escape from afghanistan
under the taliban and that doesn't feel
like america is back she she's worried
she's concerned that america has
forgotten afghanistan well we haven't
forgotten are 76 000 afghans who are
living in the united states who weren't
living here in august and virginia
actually the state that i represent is
one of the most common places folks came
to virginia initially
the resettlement processing was largely
done in virginia and the permanent
residences of many of these are in
virginia now there's many more who want
to come and we're going to work on them
but we have not forgotten that at all
but what president biden
concluded and i agreed with this
conclusion is we had done as much with
the military as we could do and the next
chapter in afghan life had to be
primarily directed by afghans and the
continuing military presence of the u.s
after 20 years
should it be for 30 years should it be
for 50 years and so he made that painful
decision and part of the decision i
think the only way to understand it is
also we we now view sort of the
russia and china as the great
threats the great adversaries
for a long time we defined our adversary
primarily as non-state terrorism but now
we're seeing a different threat from
china and russia in particular and that
means we have to redeploy resources
against the most significant challenges
that we face and that's another reason
why 20 years of military investment in
afghanistan should come to an end if
that makes sense on paper but the
reality was very messy it wasn't a good
withdrawal
and now the country's on the brink of
famine and and yemen is and sudan is and
ethiopia is and ukraine as a breadbasket
of the world that will create famine
issues around the country and we have an
obligation uh through our humanitarian
budget and in other diplomatic ways to
try to provide support for afghans and
we're going to uh but but the military
engagement needed to come to an end of
course
now looking back and looking towards
ukraine and what's happened there
president zielenski has given an
interview to the economist in which he
talked about western countries which
either want a long war to exhaust russia
or those who are more concerned about
humanitarian and economic side effects
who want a short war
which camp does america fit into we we
want a short war the biden
administration has decided that there
should not be at this moment there
should not be u.s troops in or over
ukraine but the scale of military
support that we're providing ukrainians
is massive
three billion dollars of u.s military
aid went to ukraine from 2014 through
the end of 21 a billion of that in 2021
we've just voted to send about 6.7
billion dollars of military aid to
ukraine and an equal amount of
humanitarian aid and other nations are
doing the same but i will
uh credit president zolensky that
we're we are not seeing
the
result as quickly as any of us would
like the economic pressure campaign
canceling nordstrom 2 u.n resolutions
the intense sanctions banning russian
oil imports these are all having a very
significant effect on russia just as our
military aid is helping uh ukrainians
extract great costs from russia but
we're not seeing a positive outcome as
quickly as any of us would like do you
think america has done enough
i think we i think we can do more and we
are doing more i think this very
bipartisan vote to do the 13 and a half
billion dollars of military and
humanitarian aid combined with the work
that president biden and the team has
done to encourage other countries to do
a lot it's pretty significant as you
know emma when you see non-nato nations
like sweden and finland putting military
aid into the ukrainian defense force and
considering joining nato which would
have been an anthem of five years ago in
those countries when you look at germany
sending military to ukraine they've had
a tradition of not putting military aid
into conflict zones since the end of
world war ii when you look at
switzerland being willing to play a
really important role in the sanctions
nations are getting off the sidelines
and realizing this is a fight between
democracy and tyranny and democracy has
to win there's been multiple reports of
war crimes now including the raping of
ukrainian women
russian authorities have denied all
if the evidence is there do you think
we'll ever see putin in the hague on
charges we n we need to um i started to
call for this
really at the end of the first week of
the war at the end of february because
it appeared to me that there was this
indiscriminate targeting of civilians
um which is you know the war is illegal
in and of itself the invasion of
sovereignty but when you target
civilians that's a war crime and i
believe he needs to get the slogan on
milosevic treatment and the u.s needs to
press for that will we see him
in the hague
we need to do everything we can to make
sure that he is how could you do that
you would have to find
some agreement within the u.n
to press forward on that as was done in
the case of the balkans now russia's a
security council member has the ability
within the security council to exercise
a veto but they don't have a veto on
everything within the general assembly
so we would need to look at the broader
u.n to see whether we could promote
a similar tribunal as was the case in
the balkans now none of this will shame
putin i don't believe he can be shamed
but it might shame russians to be a
pariah nation led by a leader who's a
war criminal so you seem utterly
shameless
personally yes but again the
not everyone in russia not all the
leadership and certainly not the
citizenry um are without shame the
russian people are strong people and
good people and i think if they had
access to information which they don't
um i i think they would be ashamed uh
that their nation is being led by
somebody who is committing war crimes
how do you explain the invasion how can
you try and understand what it's all
about because
we're now looking at as you say a much
longer fight than perhaps either side
could ever have imagined i mean it's an
interesting question let me let me take
you back a little bit um the u.s and
european allies were seeing the same
data uh and president zielinski too the
uh amassing of troops on the border
exercises uh in belarus but we were
interpreting the data differently and
during my time in the senate there
hasn't been as wide a divergence the u.s
was interpreting the data as there's
going to be an invasion most of the
european nations and president zielinski
they were at least saying we don't think
that's going to happen now there might
have been a little bit of
diplomacy in those words but there was
some sharp difference of opinion about
whether this was just a border exercise
to flex or whether there was going to be
an invasion the u.s intelligence was
right about this how do i explain it um
i
believe
although the countries are very
different and the individuals are very
different vladimir putin and xi jinping
are similar in that they
each have uh an ideal for their country
that i would call they they kind of view
themselves as historical rejuvenators
they're trying to rejuvenate something
that they felt was lost in the past and
that explains china aspirations with
respect to taiwan and explains putin's
aspirations with respect to ukraine
particularly because in his view modern
russia started with the christianization
of russia which began in ukraine and so
in his mind there's sort of this
mythology about what the greater russia
is and ukraine is very central to that
can i ask you something about uh your
leader president biden in march on a
visit to poland
an important visit where he said nine
words for god's sake this man cannot
remain in power talking about putin
as someone who is very familiar with how
diplomacy works how it should work
where were you when you heard what he
had said and what was your reaction
well i wouldn't have said it
i wouldn't have said it because the u.s
neither the united states nor the biden
administration considers regime change
as an element of foreign policy now in
the past the u.s did that and often got
it wrong we failed so often when we
attempted to presume who another
country's leaders should be
president biden said pretty plainly look
regime change isn't the u.s policy but i
was just speaking out of my sense of
moral outrage at the activities of
vladimir putin and i credit him for that
one of the things about joe biden that i
really like is he's a man who speaks
from the heart and it's not going to
always be poll tested or everything that
has to be written by five speech writers
and so he was expressing an outrage that
frankly the entire world feels and those
words did bring some comfort to
ukrainians and russian opposition but
the us doesn't have a policy of regime
but it was it was it was clumsy from
your ultimate diplomat more than clumsy
in fact i mean i i think it's important
to hear what you think about the idea
that this is the greatest gift for the
russian propaganda machine well um i i
don't again i wouldn't have said it but
i will say one of the biden's strengths
is he plays from the heart
um
it's not all poll tested and it's not
all eight speech writers control what he
says he plays from the heart and that so
did donald trump that statement did
express a very sincere revulsion
uh at what putin is doing but
the world should be i recognize you
wouldn't say sorry to cut across you
senator but yeah you know if donald
trump had said that people on your side
of politics would be jumping all over
that saying he doesn't know how to do
diplomacy these are the sorts of gaffes
that we shouldn't be hearing this isn't
the way that we do politics because his
whole president biden's whole play was
diplomacy is back
the great but i just i did i disagree
with you i don't think there's any
equivalence between the two um and
frankly what we had with donald trump
was cozying up to vladimir putin i mean
at least joe biden sees vladimir putin
for who he is i mean let's be honest
here the guy has invaded a country
illegally and he's committing war crimes
joe biden sees that for what it is
donald trump admired that about vladimir
putin so there's no real equivalence
between them president trump's not in
this particular scenario at this time of
course much criticism has been leveled
at him about exactly as you described
but i'm i'm more trying to say here
you've got the president of the united
states billing himself as the
experienced diplomat
and there he goes and says something
which really is a gift for putin
all right so put put that on one side of
the ledger and then on the other side of
the ledger put uh persuaded the germans
to cancel the nordstrom 2 pipeline
assembled
an international sanctions regime that's
been joined by dozens and dozens of
countries
reinvigorated nato's commitment to
defense of democracies got non-nato
nations to also agree to send military
aid into ukraine i i agree you can put
those comments on the negative side of
the ledger but i think the positive side
of the ledger is is much longer with
respect to what's going on right now in
ukraine as you would see it and those
are important points and of course many
people also talking about you know
nobody wanted this war nobody wanted
this invasion but there has been greater
unity of nato because of it and that
strengthening of the alliance i suppose
it just also allows me to to put to you
some of the concerns some have had not
just in america but around the world
that perhaps joe biden this maybe adds
to the perception that when he does
ad-lib and he gets it wrong from the
perspective of not recommending regime
change that perhaps he isn't as fit or
quite as up to the job as some have been
concerned about polls in america have
shown concerns about the fact he's
nearly 80 and in november for instance
his team put out a statement saying he
had developed a stiffer less fluid gait
as a result of his advancing age
he's 80 years old
but i can tell you from personal
experience i was with the president
two fridays ago when he invited me to
the oval office with the family of a
new york physician who died by suicide
in the early days of covet in april of
2020 and we got a bill passed in her
honor
to try to make sure that our health care
providers get mental health resources
that they need i saw that in the oval
office when he
you know pulled aside lorna's mother and
sister and brother-in-law's side and
said hey i've lost two kids i know how
you feel and and i admire that you're
taking the pain in your lives and you're
trying to do something good for others
out of it that's all we can do
in moments like that
you could hardly ask for
a better leader when you're connecting
with people in tough circumstances and
there's a lot of tough things going on
in our country and in the world right
now and i think joe biden is sort of a a
man for this moment
again and and of course you know
describing that i'm sure it was a very
emotional time to be with those people
and connecting uh through such emotional
times and such difficult times and i
know that you talking about covid have
had your own experience of connecting
with people because i believe that you
you've been suffering from long covert
yeah i wouldn't use the word suffering i
would use the word experiencing i got
coven emma right at the beginning in in
march of 2020 when we were here passing
the cares act the first big coveted
relief bill and
we still didn't understand covet that
well and i had very non-standard
symptoms but then as soon as i went home
i gave kova to my wife just one more
thing to feel guilty about and her
symptoms were really normal so oh wow
this is what we have we had mild cases
both of us by mid-april 2020
we were essentially you know back to
work and doing everything we do but i
had this one weird thing as soon as i
got covered just like this um every
nerve ending in my body just started to
kind of tingle or buzz
24 7 365 i describe it as like every
nerve ending has had five cups of coffee
and it's not painful and i can work and
i can exercise and i can sleep and i i
recognize that you don't want to say
you're suffering in light of those who
are having far more serious symptoms but
that is still a striking thing that your
body doesn't feel the same as it used to
and and
you know it must be frustrating i
imagine at times just to feel different
in yourself yeah it is it's just it's
frustrating i will say that i you know a
neurologist told me i mean for folks who
might know be experiencing this that a
neurological after effect of a virus is
not uncommon it's not the most common
thing but it's also not uncommon and not
just covet other viruses can have a
neurological after effect and my
neurologist said you know look the good
news is the neurological after effects
usually don't get worse the bad news is
they may not get better and it has just
been sort of constant now for two years
it's not even a new normal because i i
just i if it was a new normal i wouldn't
notice it but i notice it all the time
but again it just connects me with
people who are dealing with it and i i
started to talk about it in committee
hearings because i wanted folks watching
you know there was at least somebody on
the deus who believed them many long
coveted sufferers are not being believed
yes but just because you mentioned work
there and also covered and the time of
reflection people have had i was looking
back at your career and thinking about
what you have or haven't done or nearly
done and
you you've nearly been vice president
twice i understand uh nearly to
president obama losing out to a certain
joe biden and then nearly of course with
hillary clinton uh winning the popular
vote
but still just not getting there how
have you come to peace with that senator
i call myself an electoral college
dropout
um
you know
if you're in this line of work
there's wins and losses
before i was in politics i had a very
high stakes legal practice
uh trying cases i won the biggest civil
rights jury verdict in the history of
the united states i also walked somebody
into the death chamber in virginia and
held his hand while they strapped him
down to execute them you have wins and
losses um and you know life just
produces that as soon as you think
things are going well watch out and on
your darkest day a window will open and
that's you know i i'm 64. i'm i'm a lot
wiser than i was when i was half my age
but i just feel like
a life fully lived is going to be ups
and downs and you know you're right i
was nearly vice president twice and what
that tells me is i'm not supposed to be
vice president so i i and i love and i
love being a senator i love being a
senator it was a it was tough to to be
on a ticket in 2016 and lose i was so
thrilled i helped president obama become
the first african-american president
united states i threw everything into
helping hillary clinton become the first
woman president united states to win the
popular vote by a significant margin and
yet fall short yeah it was tough but um
i just came back to work the next day
the senate was open and just started
working hard and that's what i've been
doing
you just went you just went back in the
next the next time i'll tell you i'll
tell you an interesting story we we
conceded on in a speech wednesday the
day after the election the senate was
closed that week senate reopened on
monday came back to work early monday
morning first colleague who came to see
me
on that first monday after the election
in 2016 was john mccain i'm in
the office that john mccain used to have
he moved around the corner to take john
kerry's office when john kerry became
secretary of state got a knock at the
door that morning and it's john mccain
he said i want to come see you i got to
tell you you and i are the only people
in the senate who have gone through what
you've just gone through we're the only
two now that have been on a national
ticket and lost and i was running for
president so it's even more painful than
what you're going through and i'll tell
you i've got the solution for you and i
said i'm all ears he said just go right
back to work i said you found me here
first thing the first day we're open you
found me here didn't you and then john
used to say to me he was my chairman in
armed services about every three or four
months he'd say are you doing what i
told you are you doing what i told you
and so he he kind of you know was giving
me a pep talk um but that that really is
the the answer because every day
every day my staff and i we have the
opportunity to lighten somebody's burden
help of veterans get a get you know a
veteran's benefit help stop somebody
from getting their home foreclosed i got
a great bill passed in the foreign
relations committee yesterday sort of a
historic one if we can get it finally
done to say that no president of the
united states can withdraw from nato
without congressional approval so every
day we've got a chance to do something
good and most days we do
and um you know that that helps you get
over this thing of a loss i mean i
thought he was gonna say i've got the
answer for you here's a beer and here's
a whiskey chaser
[Laughter]
i mean well we we did that too but that
was not the that was that would have
been win or lose he was this was the
advice for if you've lost
it's been fascinating to talk to you
senator thank you very much for your
time i'm really glad we could do this
thank you and thank you for being with
us so much then until we meet again take
care and goodbye
[Music]
you